it was 1964 zambia gains independence
from britain
for many who were there it was a time
for new beginnings
people had high expectations from
zambia's first president
kenneth kawanda it was an exciting time
as one by one liberation movements in
africa gained independence from their
colonial masters
kawunda ruled zambia for nearly three
decades in what was effectively
a one-party state as life got tougher
for the poor
many became frustrated and angry some
blame the struggling economy
on kawunda's socialist policies as his
popularity waned
zambians had had enough after 27 years
in power
zambia's founding father was defeated at
the polls
then he did something that's still very
rare in africa he accepted defeat
and willingly stepped down he had been
forced from the political arena through
the ballot box
but he didn't disappear in the years
that followed he had a troubled
relationship with subsequent zambian
governments
at one point he was accused of plotting
a coup and then had to fight to retain
his zambian citizenship
in court later he became very much the
eldest statesman
engaged in numerous charities and
gradually winning back the trust and
affection
of many zambians many say they'll always
remember his trademark white
handkerchief but also the fundamental
role he played helping other
neighbouring countries gain their
independence
for years zambia offered refuge to
african national congress members
during apartheid in south africa the
anc's radio freedom was allowed to
broadcast
from the capital lusaka
it was under kawanda's protection that
the anc waste first
an armed struggle then a diplomatic one
against the apartheid regime
zambia also helped zimbabwe gain its
independence from white minority rule
in 1980 and after a long life spent at
the center of politics
kawuna lived out his final years at home
in the country he loved
the zambia he had helped lead to freedom
his commandment is